This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难成长的学问》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。这个空间聚焦于黑人男性的生活经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他地方其实并不安全，但你正与一位深谙此道的持牌专业人士一起倾听。有多少男人穿着一套隐形的铠甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力就非得这么做，倾听并学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
用艰难的方式在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）被指控生下了双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾多次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你最终就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的幸存者。收听《2%》。即TWO percent，在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应得的惩罚。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world.
相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜，相信我，宝贝》（Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe），在iHeart radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》（The psychology of your 20s），这是一个我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化与过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落。
It is so great to have you here, as always, back for another episode as we dive into the psychology of our 20s. So I want to talk about something today that I have been struggling with recently. You know, I'm just going to jump straight into the point. I don't know about you, but I have been really experiencing this strange sense of just dissatisfaction towards my life recently, a lingering kind of buzzing sense of exhaustion, an aimlessness, a kind of like a boredom when it comes to my interests, my future, my relationships, my health, my life in general, it's been really bothering me as someone who is very proactive.
很高兴能像往常一样在这里陪伴大家，开启新的一期节目，深入探讨我们二十多岁的心理。所以今天我想聊聊一个我最近一直在苦恼的话题。你知道，我打算直接切入正题。我不知道你们怎么样，但我最近确实经历了一种奇怪的生活失落感，一种挥之不去的疲惫感、漫无目的感，对我的兴趣、未来、人际关系、健康以及整个生活产生了一种类似厌倦的情绪，这真的让我很困扰。作为一个非常积极主动的人
when it comes to just like actually enjoying my life, I like feeling excited about things. I like feeling optimistic about the future. And that just hasn't seemed to be the case recently. And I've been really looking into what it might be. The biggest thing for me has been low energy, not being able to kind of show up in my friendships as I would like. I cannot tell you the number of plans. I have cancelled in the last three months.
至于真正享受生活，我喜欢对事物感到兴奋。我喜欢对未来保持乐观。但最近情况似乎并非如此。我一直在深入探究原因。对我和我来说，最大的问题是精力不足，无法像我希望的那样投入到友情中。我数不清在过去三个月里我取消了多少个计划。
And I've kind of just reached the conclusion. that I've lost my spark a little bit. I've lost the buzz, the love, the thrill for life. And I don't think that I am the only one. You know, our 20s come with a lot of expectations that are hard to ignore. There is so much hype around these being like the best years of your life, filled with adventure and sleepless nights and random friendships and relationships and these warm, brilliant memories you'll get to look back on for years to come. And I think maybe this is what we would define as our spark, like an enthusiasm to go out and grab life and to be interested and interesting. Our spark is the thing that kind of keeps us passionate about showing up in the world.
我差不多得出了这样的结论：我的灵气（spark）有点消失了。我失去了对生活的热情、喜爱和那种心跳加速的感觉，而且我觉得我不是唯一的一个。你知道，我们的二十岁伴随着许多难以忽视的期望。人们对这段被称为人生中最美好时光的岁月寄予了太多的炒作，充满了冒险、不眠之夜、随性的友情和恋情，以及那些你能在未来几年回味无穷的温暖而美好的回忆。我想也许这就是我们可以定义为我们的“火花”（spark）的东西，比如一种走出去拥抱生活、保持兴趣和有趣的热情。我们的火花正是让我们对在这个世界上展现自我保持热忱的东西。
And it keeps us passionate about who we are and the experiences that we're having. It's what makes us inspired and kind and engaged and motivated and present. But we can't be that all the time. You can't really be living in the golden bubble every minute of every day. There will come a time as I guess I'm experiencing right now as we speak where the energy and the excitement for life kind of dips. You become very detached from that person that you love, that person that you are at your core. and everything around you seems to lose a bit of color. You lose that kind of energy that you bring into conversations, that energy that you bring into your daily life.
它让我们对自己的身份和所经历的事情保持热情。正是这种热情让我们受到启发、心存善意、积极参与、充满动力且活在当下。但我们不可能时时刻刻都保持这样。你不可能一年365天、一天24小时都生活在黄金泡沫之中。正如我此刻正在经历的那样，总会有那么一个时刻，对生活的激情和兴奋感会开始消退。你会变得与那个你深爱的自己、那个你内心的自己严重脱节，你身边的万物似乎都失去了一些色彩。你失去了那种带入对话的活力，那种融入日常生活的热情。
And for me, I've been really reflecting on this, and I've been thinking about the person I was three or four years ago who just seemed so in love with life and really wondering where she's gone, whether I can get her back, but also whether I want her back or whether it's just a general disconnection. So we're going to talk about that today. I want to talk about why we lose our spark, why it is such a common experience,
对我来说，我一直在反思这一点，我在想三四年前那个似乎如此热爱生活的自己，真的在想她去哪儿了，我是否能把她找回来，但同时也在想我是不是真的想找回她，还是这只是一种普遍的疏离感。所以我们今天要聊聊这个。我想谈谈为什么我们会失去灵气，为什么这是一种如此普遍的体验，
the reasons behind that. It may be burnout, it may have been a breakup, but then also six tips for regaming that motivation and that love for life. Losing your spark could be for a number of reasons, but there are four main explanations that I think stand out to me, especially in our 20s. The first, the biggest one really, is burnout,
背后的原因。可能是职业倦怠，可能是经历了一场分手，但同时也有六个重新找回这种动力和对生活的热爱的建议。失去灵气的原因可能有很多，但我认为有四个主要原因对我来说尤为显眼，尤其是在我们二十多岁的时候。第一，也是最重要的一点，实际上就是职业倦怠，
pushing ourselves too hard for too long and ignoring the warning signs that we need rest and we need time to actually process our lives, our emotions, and all the activity that is going on. We're seeing a lot of research that burnout is becoming a lot more common during this day and age, especially amongst people under the age of 30. Now, I think the reason for this is twofold.
我们把自我逼得太紧、时间太长，却忽视了我们需要休息的警告信号，我们需要时间来真正处理我们的生活、情绪以及正在发生的一切活动。我们看到大量研究表明，在这个时代，职业倦怠变得越来越普遍，尤其是在30岁以下的人群中。现在，我认为原因有两个方面。
Number one, we're obviously quite new to the workplace, but also new to life. We don't really know or aren't able to express our limits, our points of exhaustion. But secondly, I think it's because of this expectation to be doing everything, to be constantly and always aiming for more. you have to be focused at school or in your job whilst also having a lot of fulfilling friendships
第一，我们显然对职场相当陌生，对生活也同样陌生。我们并不真正了解也无法表达自己的极限、精疲力竭的点。但其次，我认为这是因为这种期望——要面面俱到，要不断地、永远地追求更多。你必须专注于学业或工作，同时还要维持许多充实的人际关系
and then hobbies and a loving relationship and perfect physical and mental health, whilst also been able to, you know, juggle your family and a side hustle and your own needs. If that feels impossible to you, you are not the only one. Each of us has an individual threshold for how much stress, activity, mental exhaustion that we can tolerate. and I think as we slowly reach that threshold, we start sacrificing elements of our well-being to keep up with what is expected of us and what we expect from ourselves. And that includes very tangible things like sleep, self-care, exercise, downtime. Those are normally the first things to go when we're burnt out.
然后是各种爱好、一段充满爱意的感情以及完美的身体和心理健康，同时还要能够，你知道的，兼顾家庭、副业和自己的需求。如果这听起来对你来说不可能完成，那么你并不是唯一一个。我们每个人对于所能承受的压力、活动、精神疲惫都有一个个人的阈值。而且我认为，当我们慢慢接近那个阈值时，我们开始牺牲幸福感的各个部分，去迎合别人对我们的期望以及我们对自己的期望。这包括非常具体的事情，比如睡眠、自我保健、锻炼、停机时间。当我们精疲力竭时，这些通常是最先被抛弃的东西。
And also more intangible things like mental rest, thinking time, a space for, imagination and creativity. You need all of these things to keep your spark a light. It's hard to prioritize the things that make you excited for life, the small joys or even the energy for the big things. If you are struggling with prolonged, you know, prolonged exhaustion, prolonged fatigue, burnout from a lack of life balance or kind of academic or personal overload. We are seeing so much of this recently, and it also is demonstrating a lot of links to an increased vulnerability to illness, increased feelings of pessimism, inadequacy, none of which I think seem to go hand in hand with feeling like yourself or feeling like your spark is a light and alive.
还有一些更无形的东西，比如精神休息、思考时间、想象力和创造力空间。你需要所有这些东西来让你的灵气之火不灭。如果你正在与长期的，你知道的，长期的精疲力竭、长期的疲劳、由于缺乏生活平衡或学术/个人负担过重导致的职业倦怠作斗争，你就很难优先考虑那些让你对生活感到兴奋的事情，无论是微小的快乐，还是追求宏大事务的精力。我们最近看到了太多这样的现象，这也表明它与对疾病的脆弱性增加、悲观情绪的增加、无能感之间存在许多联系，而我认为这些似乎都与感觉自己像自己，或者感觉自己的灵气被点亮且充满活力格格不入。
So the second factor that I think contributes to losing our spark is a lingering or pre-existent, mental health disorder or challenge that may be getting out of control or becoming a little bit unmanageable, whether that is anxiety, depression, ADHD, some other condition. When it impacts our cognitions, our mood, our emotions, this condition is going to impact our so-called spark and most importantly our way of relating to the world. So many factors impact this and sometimes there really isn't an explanation for why your mental health is suddenly not as good. But I don't think anyone really talks about how physically tiring it is to have to put 100% of your energy into just convincing yourself to do even the smallest of tasks. I think maintaining your spark and all the activities that promote this part of you is a luxury when you're just trying to get by day by
所以，我认为导致我们失去灵气的第二个因素是挥之不去或先前存在的心理健康障碍或挑战，这些问题可能已经失控或变得有点难以管理，无论是焦虑、抑郁、多动症还是其他情况。当它影响我们的认知、情绪和情感时，这种状况就会影响我们所谓的灵气，最重要的是，影响我们与世界建立联系的方式。有太多因素影响着这一点，有时你的心理健康为什么突然变差确实没有任何解释。但我认为没有人真正讨论过，把100%的精力投入到说服自己去完成哪怕是最小的任务中，在体力上是多么令人疲惫。当你只是试图日复一日地勉强度日时，维持你的灵气以及所有促进这一部分的活动就是一种奢侈。
day. The third contributing factor, I think, is not spending enough time with your own thoughts or operating from a place of external validation. I think when we live for others, how are we really meant to pull from that internal source of meaning and passion and mission? How are we meant to feel like ourselves when we are engaging in extreme people pleasing? When we do feel unnecessarily guilty for other people's emotions or feelings. When we say yes, when we really want to say no, when we have no social boundaries, when we take on others' opinions or try and impress people at the expense of our own mental health, if our spark is cultivated from our own internal mental energy source, from being connected and attached and knowledgeable about who we are, when all of that
我认为第三个贡献因素是没有花足够的时间与自己的想法相处，或者从外部验证的角度来运作。我认为当我们为他人而活时，我们又怎么能真正从那种内在的意义、激情和使命的源泉中汲取力量呢？当我们陷入极端的取悦症时，我们又怎么能觉得自己还是自己呢？当我们为别人的情绪或感受感到不必要的内疚时。当我们明明想说不却说了好，当我们没有社交边界，当我们为了迎合他人而牺牲自己的心理健康去接受别人的观点时，如果我们的灵气是由我们内在的精神能量源泉培育出来的，来自于对自己的连接、依恋和了解，当所有这些时间都用在思考别人身上时，我们内心深处的那个部分就会被忽视。
time is devoted to thinking about others, that part of us becomes neglected. And the final factor, this one is a little bit different from what we've just spoken about, but it is the end of a relationship. I really do see that as a catalyst for losing a little bit of your passion and your, just your love for who you are and your love for life and the energy that you bring into, literally just your daily activities. So, when we lose a relationship, whether that is with a boyfriend or a girlfriend or a really close friend, that creates a massive shift in us. It is a complete severance from part of ourselves that was connected to this other person. It would often, I would say, also trigger a really significant dip in self-esteem, feeling very lost because we attach so much
最后一个因素，这个因素跟我们刚刚谈论的稍微有些不同，那就是一段关系的结束。我确实认为这是失去一点激情、对自我的热爱、对生活的热爱以及你投入到日常生活中的活力的催化剂。所以，当我们失去一段关系时，无论是与男友、女友还是非常亲密的朋友，这都会在我们体内产生巨大的转变。这是与这个他人相连的一部分自我的彻底割裂。我可以说，这通常也会引发自尊心的急剧下降，感到非常迷失，因为我们将太多的身份认同寄托在我们所爱的人身上。你知道，他们支撑着我们。他们让我们觉得被看见。他们见证了我们的生活。但我也认为，当这样的关系结束时，它们也会给我们带来很多心碎和许多动荡，这通常是因为会出现一个自满的时刻。所以我想，当我们处于一段长期关系中，或者处于这种长期的依赖性友谊中时，有时我们变得非常容易，变得只看得到他们，
of our identity to those we love. You know, they hold us up. They make us feel seen. They bear witness to our lives. But they can also, I think, cause us a lot of heartache and a lot of disruption when relationships like this end, often because there comes a moment of complacency. So I think when we are in a long-term relationship or we are in this long-term dependent friendship, sometimes we become very, it becomes very easy to just fall into only seeing them,
只和他们一起闲逛，和他们一起坐着看电视，而不去探索你身上的其他部分。所以当这段关系突然结束时，你就会经历一种情感真空，因为你无意中、偶然地、不由自主地为了这段关系、为了这段关系的安逸而放弃了自己的一部分。当你从这段关系中走出来时，你并不真正知道自己是谁。你并不真正知道未来会怎样。你真的不知道没有了他们，做自己意味着什么。
to only hanging out with them, to sitting, watching TV with them, to not exploring other parts of you. So when that relationship suddenly ends, you kind of experience an emotional vacuum where you have incidentally, accidentally, involuntarily given up parts of you for this relationship, for the ease of this relationship. and when you come out of it, you don't really know who you are. You don't really know what the future holds. You don't really know what it means to be you without them.
正如我所说，我认为这是一个巨大的催化剂，让人产生一种错位感，并且与那个让你成为你以及你的灵气的东西产生断开。这也揭示了我们在生活中可能一直在忽视的很多东西。那些在关系中沦为次要地位的自我部分。也许其中一个解释、其中一种情况触动了你。你真的可以在这些例子中看到自己的影子。也许你只是觉得有什么东西不见了。
And I think that is a huge catalyst, as I said, for feeling a sense of dislocation and disconnection from what makes you you and from your spark. It also just reveals so much about what we have perhaps been neglecting in our lives. the parts of ourselves that have become secondary behind the relationship. Maybe one of these explanations, one of these situations is calling to you. You can really see yourself in these examples. Maybe you just feel like there's just something missing.
这些其实都不太适用。只是生活中确实缺乏一种投入的努力。这其实并不重要，因为我认为最重要的是，此时此刻你正在经历这种体验，它让你觉得你的生活远非最佳状态，并且你觉得有什么东西是你在生活中错过了，也是从生活中没有得到的。所以，在短暂的休息之后，我将讨论六个基于研究的建议，帮助你找回你的灵气，从最简单但也是最重要的一点开始。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
None of these really apply. There's just a genuine lack of sense of effort to be put into your life. It doesn't really matter because I think that what is most important here is that right now you are having this experience that makes you feel like your life is less than optimal and that there is something that you're missing out on and missing out of getting from your life. So I'm going to talk about six research-based tips to get your spark back, starting with the most simple but the most important after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an
我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇特现代世界中建立抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们搞错了。我们在世界上恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难险阻，你最终就会成为一个更快乐、更充实、更 healthier 的人。收听《2%》，即TWO percent，在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得
escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when
有扶梯可用。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理坚韧、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的方法。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，穿透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾深信植物油天生具有炎症性。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。你还记得吗
Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What? The hell does George Bush got to do a little count? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
黛安·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击了小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。什么？乔治·布什跟小金有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个事件，剖析发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，滔滔不绝地谈论80年代的可卡因。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以谈论可卡因，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二次讨论可卡因了。所以我开始发现这里有一条主线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆上台面了。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
欢迎来到我的新播客《艰难成长的学问》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch.
我在说。特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。而我们还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在盯着记分牌。
Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
生活变成了关于赢与输。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在这个地球上做一个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way. Open your free, I Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023,
我希望你真正地成为一个好人。加入我，凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines），在我的新播客《艰难成长的学问》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你的免费I Heart Radio应用。搜索《艰难成长的学问》并立即收听。2023年，
former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckard）发现自己处于一场 paternity（亲子关系）丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这就开始了一场长达多年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾多次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才破获了此案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Nanchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男性。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·南奇尼（Michael Nanchini）。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. You need to replenish your body and your mind before you can start building back your interest in life. That is why the biggest thing for getting your spark back is prioritizing rest. It sounds so simple, but we really don't acknowledge how much of a difference, a good night's sleep or a week off can be for resetting our body,
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于要承担后果了。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有诈骗罪。在亚利桑那州正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《深陷爱河》播客。你需要先恢复身体和心灵，然后才能重新开始建立你对生活的热情。这就是为什么找回灵气最重要的事情是把休息放在首位。听起来很简单，但我们真的没有意识到，一个晚上的好睡眠或一周的假期对于重置我们的身体会有多大不同，
especially when this becomes a practice of scheduling time to do nothing, of scheduling time, to just relax in your body, in your mind, and be present. When you've pushed yourself to this cliff edge of complete exhaustion, you reach a point of internal disharmony whereby your body will literally start to shut down due to ongoing chronic stress. That doesn't sound optimal and it certainly doesn't help with getting your spark back. Sometimes we think that we need to be doing more to be more, but it's actually quite the opposite. The people who know themselves the best and get the most out of life are those who realize the value in giving their brain and their body, even their
尤其是当这变成了一种安排无所事事时间的习惯，安排时间在你的身体和思想中放松并活在当下的习惯。当你把自己逼到彻底精疲力竭的悬崖边缘时，你就会达到一种内心不和谐的状态，你的身体会因为持续的慢性压力而字面意义上开始崩溃。这听起来并不理想，而且肯定无助于找回灵气。有时我们认为我们需要做更多才能变得更多，但实际情况恰恰相反。那些最了解自己并从生活中获得最多的人，是那些意识到给自己的大脑和身体，甚至给灵魂补充能量的时间具有价值的人。如果你失去了灵气，你需要从把休息重新引入你的生活开始。这包括做一些事情，比如在需要的时候请病假，而不需要觉得你需要为此辩解。接受拒绝社交计划以待在家里放松，偶尔给自己一天什么都不做的假期。正是这些慢下来的时刻，我们的大脑终于得到了关闭的机会。你会真正惊讶于有多少想法、对未来的计划、有用的思考会浮现出来，因为你终于有了容纳它们的空间，有了处理它们的空间。
soul, time to replenish. If you've lost your spark, you need to start by reintroducing rest back into your life. And this includes by doing things like taking your sick days when you need them without feeling like you need to justify it. Being okay with saying no to plans to just chill at home, giving yourself a day every now and again to just do nothing. It's those slow moments that our brain finally gets to switch off. And you'll really be surprised about how much comes up for you, how many ideas, plans for the future, helpful thoughts arise because you finally have space to hold them in space to process them.
我确实理解，要做到这一点并接受我们需要慢下来其实相当困难。由于社会对懒惰的联想，我们对休息怀有很大的内疚感。如果你不是100%的时间都在鞭策自己，如果你不想把所有事情都做到极致，那是因为你缺乏纪律。那是因为你懒惰，而不是真正倾听身体的声音并认识到这其实更有效率。如果你是一个过度成就者，这些态度会尤为普遍，
I really do understand that it's actually quite hard to do that and accept that we need to slow down. we feel a lot of guilt towards rest because of the societal association with laziness. If you are not pushing yourself 100% of the time, if you don't want to do it all, it's because you just lack discipline. It's because you're just lazy, rather than actually listening to your body and recognizing that this is actually more efficient. I think these attitudes are especially pervasive if you're an overachiever.
或者如果你把很多价值寄托在外部成就上，重置你对休息的态度有点意味着抛弃所有带给你个人成就感或满足感的东西，比如你的成就、做一个能够逼迫自己的人、做一个享受精疲力竭的紧迫感的人。然而，这根本是不可持续的。它会导致你忽视未来自己真正需要的部分。你知道，它需要你保持坚强和健康。
or if you put a lot of worth into your external achievements, resetting your attitude towards rest kind of means unlearning everything that brings you a sense of personal fulfillment or satisfaction, like your achievements, like being somebody who can push themselves, being somebody who enjoys the urgency of exhaustion. That is just not sustainable though. And it causes you to neglect the parts of you that your future self really needs. You know, it needs you to stay strong and to stay healthy.
你的灵魂、你的自我意识，需要你真正停下来、暂停，关注你是谁以及你从生活中得到了什么。我认为休息也确实增加了我们的自我意识能力。它提高了我们的同理心。它提高了我们想象未来的能力。所以我想它为我们提供了关于我们是谁以及我们想要什么的真正的创造性和视角愿景。从而真正把我们的生活还给我们。所以，找回灵气的第二个建议是从生活中的被动接受者转变为主动执行者。我们失去灵气的原因往往是因为我们安于现状，过着仿佛处于自动驾驶状态的生活。
Your soul, your sense of self, needs you to actually stop and pause and focus on who you are and what you're getting out of life. I think rest also just really increases our capacity for self-awareness. It improves our empathy. It improves our ability to imagine the future. So I think that it gives us a real creative and perspective vision for who we are and what we want. and in turn really gives us our life back. So my second tip for getting your spark back is to shift from a passive agent to an active agent in your life. So often the reason we lose our spark is because we settle into living as though we are on autopilot.
我想让你停下来想一想这是否就是你。事情发生在我们身上。生活发生在我们身上。我们只是勉强接受现状。当我们做出决定时，我们并没有掌舵多少，无论是让我们更快乐的事物，还是避免或改变那些消耗我们的环境。以这种方式生活要容易得多。每天醒来都要面对这样一个事实：你正在创造
I want you to pause and think whether that's you. Things happen to us. Life happens to us. We just kind of accept that that's the way it is. we aren't doing much steering when it comes to our decisions, to what might make us happier, to avoiding or changing circumstances that are depleting us. And it is a lot easier to live life this way. It's really tiring to have to wake up each moment and live with the fact that you are creating
你的现实，你正在创造你的未来，你在掌控一切，你有自主权，这真的很累。因为这种对责任的觉悟自然需要更多的努力，对吧？它从你身上拿走了更多。但我真心相信，这种精力的付出会在成千上万倍中得到回报，并且当我们适应一种从长远来看真正给我们想要的生活的方式，而不是短期的即时满足和小快乐时，它会变得更容易，负担也更轻。每天以60%的状态生活，拖着另外40%在前行，要远比
your reality, that you are creating your future, you are in control, you have agency. because that kind of awareness of your responsibility is naturally more effort, right? It takes a lot more from you. But I honestly believe that that expenditure of effort pays off in its thousands and becomes easier, becomes less taxing when we adjust to a way of living that actually gives us what we want in the long term rather than like the instant gratification, small pleasures in the short term. It's so much more exhausting living every day at 60% and dragging the other 40% behind you
以100%的状态生活、看到自己真正拥有目标和热情并回归生活、找回灵气要累得多。这并不是说你应该更努力地工作、做更多的事情、永远保持100%的努力和100%的能量，对吧？因为我认为这是导致纯粹精疲力竭的原因，而我们知道精疲力竭是职业倦怠的成因。相反，它是关于选择轻装生活与沉重生活的区别。当我们沉重生活时，我们实际上是从未来的自我那里借用了努力和时间。我会对此做更多解释。当你没有为
than at 100% and seeing yourself really have purpose and passion and come back into your life, getting your spark back. Now this isn't to say that you should be working harder doing more, 100% effort, 100% energy all the time, right? Because I think that is a contribution to pure exhaustion, which we know is a contributor to burnout. rather it's about choosing to live light versus live heavy when we live heavy we kind of borrow effort and time from our future selves i'm going to explain this a little bit more when you don't make
什么能让你的生活变得更好做出积极的选择时，无论是选择以感觉良好的方式滋养你的身体、在需要时选择休息、在睡前选择关掉屏幕（尽管你还想多刷一会儿手机）、选择和好人在一起，你把所有这些决定都作为后果转移到了你的未来。在短期内，你必须轻装生活，因为你做出了最简单的决定：留在床上而不是锻炼身体或见朋友，在床上玩手机多花30分钟而不是看书，牺牲睡眠，把本只需五分钟就能搞定的事情拖延。你是在从未来的自己那里偷走快乐，并通过走看似更简单但从长远来看更困难的路线来加剧疲惫，
active choices about what's going to make your life better whether that is choosing to feel your body in a way that feels good choosing to rest when you need choosing to turn off your screen before bed even though you want to scroll for a few more minutes, choosing to keep good company, you transfer all of those decisions into your future as consequences. In the short term, you've got to live light because you made the easiest decision to stay in bed rather than work out or see friends to spend that extra 30 minutes on your phone in bed rather than reading a book to sacrifice your sleep, to put things off when they would seriously only take about five minutes. You're stealing joy from your future self and contributing to exhaustion by taking what seems like the easier route,
然而从长远来看，这是更艰难的路线。我认为良好的习惯、充实的生活习惯虽然令人疲惫，但它们确实赋予了你对生活的掌控感，让你觉得你实际上可以去做你想做的事，去创造你想过的生活，并在该生活中创造意义。这意味着当你每天出现、当你醒来时，你有精力和空间去做自己，去关爱自己，通过积极参与那些致力于改善你并让你的生活更轻松的决定来找回你的灵气。我认为归根结底，这种从被动到主动的转变所包含的是：注意那些消耗你精力与为你创造精力的事物，那些让你感到不安与让你感到安慰的事物，那些让你疲惫、让你累、让你悲伤的事物，与那些让你充满活力、感到兴奋和快乐的事物。这是第一步。我认为第二步是有意识地选择你生活中那些能量消耗者的替代品。你通常会在这里看到一个难度曲线。例如，如果你让生活更轻松或轻装生活的主要举措是选择在睡前做一个创意项目，而不是无意识地看电视，
but in the long term is the harder route. I think good practices fulfilling life habits are tiring, but they do actually give you a sense of control over your life and give you a sense that you actually get to do the things you want to do and create a life you want to live and actually create meaning within that life, meaning that when you show up every single day, when you wake up, you have the energy in the space to be yourself, to show love to yourself, to get your spark back by actively engaging in decisions that are all devoted to bettering you and to making your life easier. I think at the end of the day, what this shift from passive to active entails is noticing the things that deplete your energy versus create energy for you, things that unsettle you versus
一开始总是会很难，因为我认为我们已经变得非常适应并且非常习惯于熟悉和轻松的事情，而对这种生活结构、生活常规的任何转变或改变都会打破这种常态。但随着时间的推移，当你适应后，你会发现做对自己最好的事、做有助于找回灵气的事会变得更加习惯性和自动化，做那些真正需要展现出巨大激进自我同情的事——不向即时欲望妥协，而是专注于长期幸福。我的下一个建议也许是我最喜欢的，这涉及通过在平凡中创造兴奋，重新回到生活中充满激情、兴趣和快乐的地方。一次又一次让我重新与真实的自我建立联系的最大秘诀，是寻找快乐而不是寻找抱怨的事情，积极寻找那些让我感到幸福、兴奋、惊讶或感恩自己是人类的事物，而不是总是陷入我的负面偏误中。我是通过连接我的内在小孩并回到童年的惊叹与好奇状态来做到这一点的。你的内在小孩是你身上最充满活力、最不受束缚、最兴奋的部分。我认为变老最悲伤的事情之一，就是发现一切
comfort you, things that make you fatigued, make you tired, make you sad versus things that make you energized and excited and joyful. That's the first step. I think the second step is like really consciously choosing the alternative to those energy takers in your life. You typically, I think, see a difficulty curve occur here. For example, if you're big thing for making your life easier or living light is choosing to do a creative project before bed rather than just mindlessly watch TV.
都变得更加灰暗，我们失去了一种仿佛再也找不回的光芒，但我认为我们可以。我们可以重新获得年轻时的那种惊叹感。通过寻找能让我们惊叹的事物，而不是寻找让我们失望的事物。你知道的，变色树叶、你在上班路上每天看到的那只猫、吃一块美味的糕点或美味的水果、对陌生人微笑并让他们回笑，就像你最喜欢的艺术家在超市的收音机里播放、树上的一只酷虫、跟着你最喜欢的电视剧的主题曲一起唱歌，快乐真的
it's always going to be hard at the beginning because I think that we become very adjusted and very comfortable in what is familiar and what is easy and any shift or change to that kind of life structure, life routine. It's going to disrupt that norm. But over time as you adjust, you'll see that it becomes a lot more kind of habitual and automatic to do the thing that is best for you and to do the thing that helps you get your spark back that do the thing that really involves showing yourself a lot of radical self-compassion by not giving into your immediate wants but focusing on your long-term well-being. My next tip is perhaps my favorite and this involves getting back to that place of passion,
无处不在。这是一种奇怪的感觉，因为它是少数几种当你寻找它时你会发现它希望被你找到的情感之一，对吧？就像，如果你寻找幸福，你并不总能找到它，但如果你寻找快乐，你肯定能找到。当你训练自己去寻找敬畏并发现快乐时，你也会开始注意到你的想法和认知开始转变并变得更加积极，你也会慢慢找回对生活的光芒和欣赏。与内在小孩建立联系的另一部分是允许自己玩耍。玩耍其实真的很有趣。这就像是全部的意义所在，对吧，就是从悬在你头顶的所有其他事情中解放出来，进入你的身体，进入你的快乐，进入
interest and joy in life by creating excitement in the mundane. The biggest thing that gets me back in touch with my true self time and time again is looking for joy rather than looking for things to complain about, actively searching for things that make me happy and elated or surprised or grateful to be human rather than always buying into my negativity bias. And I do this by connecting with my inner child and getting back to a place of childhood wonder and curiosity. Your inner child is the most alive version of you there is, the least uninhibited, the most excited. And I think it's one of the saddest things about getting older is finding that everything
当下。研究确实表明，成年后的玩耍让我们能够以一种不受结构限制和富有创意的方式行事，它能降低压力水平。它当然能提高创造力，还能增加我们大脑中的神经元连接，因为我们参与了使用大脑不同部位的不同活动，而这些部位通常是不相交的。任何带给你快乐或兴奋的娱乐活动都算作玩耍。你知道，它可以是一个电子游戏。它可以是一项运动，特别是如果它是社交运动。
becomes a lot more gray, that there is a certain glimmer that we lose that. It feels like we can't get back, but I think that we can. We can achieve that sense of wonder that we had when we were younger. By looking for things to be amazed about rather than things to be disappointed over. you know, the leaves changing color, the cat you see every day on your walk to work, eating a really tasty pastry or a tasty piece of fruit, smiling at a stranger, having them smile back, like your favorite artist, playing over the radio at the supermarket, a cool bug on a tree, singing along to like the opening track of your favorite TV show, joy really
它可以在你的闲暇时间写一些小诗，画画，我不知道，蹦床。字面意思去你当地公园的公共秋千上荡秋千，去海滩游泳。那就是玩耍。这再次成为快乐进入你生活的一条途径，让你感觉自己奇妙、充满好奇、沉浸在环境和周围事物中，而不是像被困在一堵负面情绪的玻璃墙后面。感觉自己像是在看着生活从身边溜走，却无法伸手去触摸它。我认为重新与那个孩子气的自己建立联系，是对所有让我们保持断开的压力和责任的绝妙转移，因为它让我们滑回一种
is everywhere. And it's a strange feeling because it's one of the few emotions that when you you search for it, you'll notice that it wants you to find it, right? Like, if you look for happiness, you can't always find it, but if you look for joy, you most certainly will. As you kind of train yourself to look for awe and to discover joy, you also begin to notice that your thoughts and cognitions begin to transform and become more positive, and you slowly get that glow and appreciation for life back. Another part of getting in touch with your inner child is allowing yourself to be playful. Play is honestly so much fun. That's like the whole point, right, to just be free of everything else that's hanging over you and to get into your body, to get into your joy, to get
毫无束缚、无忧无虑、对生活充满活力的视角。我真的、真的很恳求你尝试一下，即使你觉得尴尬或觉得土。这无关乎别人怎么想。这关乎什么能让你感觉最好。我认为这里的重点是，灵气在变淡后重新找回它，并不完全是内在的。它还关乎你为自己创造的外部环境。我认为部分原因在于你对生活的热爱和活力的丧失归结为缺乏灵感，感觉自己陷入常态，没有新的想法，没有新的信念，没有体验到新的感官、新的感觉、新的兴趣。我想你只是变得非常麻木和关闭。当生活开始
into the moment. And studies have really shown that play in adulthood lets us act in a way that is unstructured and creative and it reduces stress levels. It increases creativity, of course, along with the number of neural connections we have in our brain because we engage in different kinds of activities that use different parts of our brain that normally don't talk to each other. Anything you do recreationally that brings you joy or excitement counts as play. You know, it could be a video game. It could be playing sport, especially if it's social sport.
融入当下。研究确实表明，成年后的玩耍能让我们以一种无结构且有创意的方式行事，它能降低压力水平。它当然能提高创造力，还能增加我们大脑中的神经连接数量，因为我们参与了不同类型的活动，动用了大脑中平时互不相干的不同区域。任何能带给你快乐或兴奋的休闲活动都算作玩耍。你知道，它可以是一个电子游戏。它可以是进行体育运动，尤其是社交性运动。
It could be writing little poems in your spare time, painting, I don't know, trampolining. literally going on the public swing at like your local park, going for a swim at the beach. That is play. And it once again is an avenue for joy to enter your life and to keep you feeling like wonderful and curious and engaged in your environment and your surroundings rather than kind of stuck behind like a glass wall of negativity. feeling like you're watching your life go by and you're not able to reach out and touch it. I think reconnecting with that childlike version of you is a wonderful diversion from all the stresses and responsibilities that do keep us disconnected because it lets us slip back into a perspective that
它可以是在你的空闲时间写小诗，画画，我不知道，蹦床。字面意思去当地公园荡秋千，去海滩游泳。那就是玩耍。这再次成为快乐进入你生活的一个途径，让你继续感受到奇妙、好奇，并与你的环境和周围事物保持连接，而不是像被困在一道负面情绪的玻璃墙后面。感觉你看着生活从眼前流逝，却无法伸手去触碰。我认为重新连接那个童年版本的自己，是摆脱那些让我们产生隔阂的压力和责任的一个绝佳转移方式，因为它让我们滑回一种
is so uninhibited, that is so carefree, that is so just like energized for life. I really, really implore you to try it even if you feel embarrassed or you feel cringe. It's not about what other people think. It's about what's going to leave you feeling your best. I think the main thing here is that getting your spark back after it's been dulled isn't all internal. It's also about the external environment you create for yourself. I think partially what losing your love and energy for life comes down to is a lack of inspiration, is feeling stuck in the norm and not having new thoughts, not having new beliefs, not experiencing new sense. sensations, new interests. I think you just become very much numb and shut down. When life starts to
毫无拘束、无忧无虑、对生活充满活力的视角。我真的、真的很恳求你去尝试一下，即使你觉得尴尬或难为情。这不是关于别人怎么想。而是关于什么能让你感觉最好。我认为这里的关键是，在火花被削弱后重新找回它，并不完全是内求的。这也关乎你为自己创造的外部环境。我认为失去对生活的热爱和能量，部分原因在于缺乏灵感，在于感觉陷入了常规而没有新的思想，没有新的信念，没有体验新的感官刺激、新的兴趣。我认为你只会变得非常麻木和封闭。当生活开始
feel plain and colorless, that is an invitation for you to add some color back in by keeping yourself inspired. And I love doing this by consuming content, media, books, articles, music, anything that gets your brain working and thinking and firing differently. start your morning off, you know, with a TED talk instead of social media, with five minutes of meditation instead of doom scrolling, with energetic music. Have like a wild dance in your bathroom in the morning. Make that part of your routine. Listen to podcasts like this one or subscribe to like a news site like the New York Times or the Atlantic. That is $5 a month for priceless access to a world that feels a lot more expensive than your day-to-day life. to hearing about what everyone's doing across the globe.
觉得平淡无奇、毫无色彩，这就是在邀请你为自己注入一些色彩，保持内心的灵感。我非常喜欢通过消费内容、媒体、书籍、文章、音乐来做到这一点，任何能让你的大脑运转、思考并产生不同火花的东西都可以。比如，早上用一场TED演讲代替社交媒体，用五分钟的冥想代替无休止地刷手机，播放动感的音乐。早上在浴室里疯狂地跳支舞。把这作为你日常生活的一部分。收听像这样的播客，或者订阅像《纽约时报》或《大西洋月刊》这样的新闻网站。每个月花5美元，就能获得无价的通道，去了解一个比你的日常生活广阔得多的世界，去听听世界各地人们都在做些什么。
I also want to recommend a book here that I think is invaluable when you're feeling like you're in a bit of a sparkless rut. The book is called The Alchemist. I'm sure a lot of you have heard about this before. It is so widely read and known for good reason because even if you're not like a big reader, this novel offers such a simple, digestible, inspiring kind of folk story about getting more out of your life, about getting more out of your
我还想在这里推荐一本书，当你觉得自己陷入了某种毫无生气的死胡同里时，这本书简直无价。这本书叫《炼金术士》。我确信你们很多人以前都听说过这本书。它被广泛阅读和熟知是有原因的，因为即使你不是一个狂热的阅读者，这部小说也提供了一个如此简单、易懂、充满启迪的民间故事，关于如何从你的生活中获得更多，从你的
dreams, out of yourself, and refocusing on your purpose, on your drive. I think that's something that we lose as life gets harder as we get older. We get stuck in our routines. And of course, we lose our spark. So I read this book in like one or two sittings a few years back. And I just started rereading it and it's incredibly eye-opening even if you've read it before honestly read it again because the message i think becomes different the older you get you interpret it differently and i think it's really valuable to seek inspiration from other people's ideas and their articulation of their mission and their and kind of how they see the world whether that is the same or different to your own at least it challenges you to think about your life differently in fact i think obviously
梦想中、从你自己身上获得更多，并重新专注于你的目标和动力。我认为随着生活变得越来越艰难，随着我们年龄的增长，我们正在失去这种东西。我们陷入了日常的琐碎之中。当然，我们也失去了活力。所以我在几年前的一两次坐立间就读完了这本书。我最近又开始重读它，它真的让人大开眼界，即使你以前读过，老实说也值得再读一遍，因为随着年龄的增长，你对信息的理解会变得不同，你的解读也会不同。我认为从别人的想法、他们对其使命的阐述以及他们看待世界的方式中寻求灵感是非常有价值的，无论这与你自己的看法相同还是不同，至少它会挑战你以不同的方式思考你的生活。事实上，我认为很显然
you know, reading a book is not a huge task. Expanding the media you consume is minor. Listening to TED Talks is pretty easy. Seeing joy in your life is not that hard. You really only need to pick out like three things a day. And I really think that all of these things, the reason why they're so powerful is because time and time again, they make you actually engage with what's around you. they make you engage with your thoughts, with your life, rather than sitting in the passenger seat. If you've lost your spark, I would really encourage you to reflect on whether the life you're currently living actually provides you with an opportunity to be in touch with life, to be alive. Routine is really great for creating structure and bringing order and productivity into our lives. But that is not what life is.
你知道，读一本书并不是一项艰巨的任务。扩展你接触的媒体是微不足道的。听TED演讲相当简单。在生活中发现快乐也并非难事。你实际上只需要每天挑出三件事。我真的认为所有这些之所以如此强大，是因为它们一次又一次地让你真正参与到你周围的事物中。它们让你参与到你的想法中，参与到你的生活中，而不是仅仅坐在副驾驶座上。如果你失去了活力，我真的鼓励你反思一下，你目前过的生活是否真的为你提供了一个与生活保持联系、去真切活着的机会。常规对于建立结构、给我们的生活带来秩序和生产力确实非常棒。但生活绝不仅仅是这些。
life is what happens around that. Life is what is spontaneous and thrilling and what gives you new stories and new feelings and new energy. So I would also say break out of the monotony by really challenging yourself to do one new thing this week, one new thing every week, even if that's alone, a new gym class, a new part of the city to explore a new dish that you're going to cook for yourself. New things are good for our emotional health because it actually really opens up our mind, I think, to the possibility of more. Like they've done research on this and the happiest people are those who really expose themselves to new things who challenge the norm, who challenge their brains to think about things differently. Because novelty also introduces excitement.
生活是这一切之余发生的事情。生活是那些自发、惊险的事物，是赋予你新故事、新感受和新能量的事物。所以我也想说，要打破单调，就要真正挑战自己在本周去做一件新事，每周做一件新事，哪怕是一个人去做，上一堂新的健身课，去探索城市的一个新角落，或者为自己做一道新菜。新鲜事物对我们的情绪健康有益，因为我真的认为它为更多的可能性打开了我们的思维。人们对此做过研究，最幸福的人往往是那些真正让自己接触新鲜事物、挑战常规、挑战大脑以不同方式思考的人。因为新鲜感也会带来兴奋感。
There is a really great article by Psychology Today that puts it like this. When we try something new, this actually opens up the possibility for you to enjoy something new. There have been entire careers, entire life paths carved out by people dipping their baby toes into small ponds and suddenly discovering a love for something they had no idea would capture their imaginations. It forces you to grow. it forces you to choose to live light by kind of living heavy and I think that you just bear witness to the parts of your identity that are allowed to kind of flourish in those moments where life isn't like easy life isn't familiar the moment that you're in you might not be comfortable but it's there that your spark really returns because you have to rely on yourself and you have to really pull from
《今日心理学》上有一篇非常棒的文章，它是这样说的：当我们尝试新事物时，这实际上为你享受新事物开启了可能。有许多完整的职业生涯和人生道路，都是由那些将脚趾探入小水塘、突然发现自己对某种原本毫无概念的事物产生热爱的人开创的。它迫使你成长。它迫使你在看似沉重的生活中选择轻盈地生活，我认为在那些生活并不轻松、生活并不熟悉的时刻，你只是见证了自己身份中那些得以蓬勃发展的特质。你所在的时刻可能并不舒适，但正是在那里，你的活力才真正回归，因为你必须依靠自己，你必须真正从
this pool of just innate joy and energy and capability. I think it's a better way to put it. All right, I have two final tips for you and we're going to keep them short and sweet. The first is to be practicing some form of movement every day. Now, this is not movement to lose weight. It's not movement to get fitter. It's not for a beauty standard, but it's because of what it will do for your brain. Now I really despise when people say that exercise is some like magical cure for mental health problems. That's literally bullshit. But we are seeing research that shows how protective physical activity is for these kinds of ruts or periods of depletion we might find ourselves in. There's actually a really special research project that was conducted in Australia by the University
这种纯粹的内在快乐、能量和能力源泉中汲取力量。我觉得这样说更恰当。好了，我最后给你两个建议，而且我们会简明扼要。首先是每天都要进行某种形式的运动。注意，这不是为了减肥而运动。这不是为了变得更健美而运动。它不是为了美标准，而是因为它将为你的大脑带来改变。现在，我非常鄙视那些说运动是治疗心理健康问题的某种神奇灵药的人。这简直是胡扯。但我们确实看到研究表明，体育活动对于我们可能发现自己陷入的这类沉闷期或精力耗竭期具有多么强的保护作用。实际上有一个非常特殊的科研项目是由澳大利亚
of Sydney, literally down the road from where I am right now. And it published, findings that unstructured dance, so not dance for the purpose of exercise even for getting your heart rate up, literally just dancing around your living room, dancing around wherever you are. It's actually one of the best things you can do for your brain and mental well-being. Besides that, exercise boosts mental energy, it boosts motivation. Those are two things that are really crucial for getting our spark back. I think it's especially impactful and special if you find time to move in nature. There is a whole field of research called eco-psychology that talks about how spending time outdoors
悉尼大学进行的，就在离我现在所在地不远的地方。它发布的研究结果表明，非结构化的舞蹈——甚至不是为了锻炼或提高心率而跳舞，字面意思就是仅仅在你的起居室里、在你所在的任何地方随性舞蹈——实际上是对你的大脑和心理健康最好的事情之一。除此之外，运动还能提升精神活力，提升动力。这两点对于我们找回活力至关重要。如果你能找到时间在大自然中运动，我觉得会更有影响力和特殊意义。有一个专门的研究领域叫做生态心理学，它讨论了在大自然中度过时间如何
promotes how we feel about ourselves and our lives and the attitudes we bring into our day-to-day. You probably already know this without me needing to tell you. You know, just think about how good you feel after you take a swim in the ocean. And have you ever felt bad after a swim in the ocean, after a hike, after you walked by the creek near your house? That's where humans are meant to be. So it's no wonder that we're losing our vibrancy and our spark and our love for life when we are living in a world that is focused on keeping us inside. I think nature provides a lot of healing in that sense for reconnecting ourselves with what it truly means to be. human, what it truly means to be alive in our bodies, how capable our bodies are, how much
促进我们对自我、生活的感受以及我们带入日常生活的态度。也许不用我提醒，你可能就已经知道了。你知道，只要想想你在海里游完泳后感觉多好。你曾在海里游泳后、远足后、或者在你家附近的小溪边散步后感觉糟糕过吗？这才是人类应该呆的地方。所以难怪当我们生活在一个专注于把我们关在室内世界里的时候，我们会失去活力、激情和对生活的热爱。我认为大自然在某种意义上提供了很多治愈，让我们重新与作为人的真正意义、与我们在身体里活着的真正意义、与我们的身体有多大潜力、
feeling our bodies can hold. That's spark. That is spark right there. Embracing what makes us wild. Embracing the beauty of the outdoors, the beauty of what comes from that and kind of watching how you're, I don't know, it just instantly fills up your cup and it keeps it full for days, even weeks after. A final tip, I think, try to spend less time thinking about what others have that you don't. And think about everything that is wonderful about your life and what you have. What are your own secret gardens? I speak about this a lot, but this is a concept I came up with.
我们的身体能承载多少情感重新建立联系。这就是活力。那正是活力所在。拥抱让我们成为野性自己的东西。拥抱大自然的美丽，拥抱由此产生的美丽，并观察你的内心——我不知道，它会瞬间充满你的杯子，并让它在之后的几天甚至几周内保持充盈。最后一个建议，我认为，尽量少花时间去想别人拥有而你没有的东西。多想想关于你的生活和拥有哪些东西是美好的。你自己的秘密花园是什么？我经常谈到这一点，这是一个我自己想出来的概念。
A while back that essentially says each of us has this like secret part of who we are locked in the back of our mind that I call our secret garden. and our secret garden is filled with the things that are special, unique, vulnerable, entirely ours. It could be, you know, the little hobby that you haven't told anybody about. The little passion project that is just yours. Your deep dives on Wikipedia, the poetry you write in your notes app. The fact that you still love music from the early 2000s. The fact that actually you're a really good singer, you just don't sing in front of other people. that you can make a really good lasagna or a really good birthday cake.
不久前，这个概念大致是说，我们每个人在心灵深处都锁着这样一部分极其私密的自我，我称之为我们的秘密花园。而我们的秘密花园里装满了那些特别的、独特的、脆弱的、完全属于我们自己的东西。它可能是，你知道的，那个你没有告诉任何人的小爱好。那个完全属于你的微小热情项目。你在维基百科上的深入搜索，你在备忘录App里写的诗。你依然喜欢2000年代初期的音乐的事实。事实上你是个很棒的歌手，只是不在别人面前唱歌。你能做出非常棒的千层面或非常棒的生日蛋糕。
Those are parts of your secret garden. They are what makes it special, what makes us happy, and we need to spend time in that garden. We need to water it. We need to share its kind of bounty with others. And you'll notice how much more alive and connected you feel when you spend less time looking over the fence at someone else's life and more time really like appreciating what you have and also just seeking to elevate that,
这些都是你秘密花园的一部分。它们是让这个花园变得特别、让我们感到快乐的东西，我们需要花时间在这个花园里。我们需要给它浇水。我们需要与他人分享它的馈赠。你会注意到，当你花更少的时间去看别人篱笆那边的生活，而花更多的时间真正去欣赏你所拥有的，并同时寻求提升它时，
seeking to be grateful but also seeking to build it even further, not for somebody else, not so that they think you're accomplished or cool or whatever it is, but because you actually want amazing things to come your way. You want a life that you feel happy with. You want your spark back. Like that's the entire point of this episode. You want to feel like there is a fire that you have in your stomach for life. So I want to finish off by saying, I'm really glad that you are here if you're feeling this way.
寻求心怀感恩但同时也寻求进一步构建它，不是为了别人，不是为了让他们觉得你很有成就感、很酷或者别的什么，而是因为你真的希望美好的事情降临到你身上。你想要一种让你感到快乐的生活。你想要找回你的活力。这正是这集节目的全部意义所在。你希望感觉自己的肚子里有一团为生活燃烧的火焰。所以我想在最后说，如果你正有这种感觉，我真的很高兴你能来到这里。
I feel you. I know this rut feels like it will last a lifetime. Like you'll never be that kind of fun person you were three, four, five years ago. And you know what? You probably won't be that person again. But you are discovering and building somebody better. You will feel excited by life again. you will fall back in love with yourself again.
我感同身受。我知道这种沉闷感感觉会持续一辈子。好像你永远也不会成为三四五年前那个有趣的自己了。你知道吗？你可能真的再也回不到那个自己了。但你正在发现并构建一个更好的自己。你将再次对生活感到兴奋。你将再次重新爱上你自己。
I just think that it requires a bit of a holistic change. It's really normal, I think, for us to find ourselves at this point of just like shallowness and hollowness and emptiness. That's kind of part of the journey, right? It's about rebuilding the things that we have perhaps been neglecting. It's about being kind of exhilarated by the mundane. It's about creating habits for your life that is going to mean. that you still feel vibrant and alive, even if you're behind a desk, working nine to five
我只是觉得这需要一点整体上的改变。我认为我们发现自己处于这种肤浅、空洞和虚无的时刻是非常正常的。这可以说是旅程的一部分，对吧？这是关于重建我们可能一直忽视的事物。这是关于从平凡中获得兴奋。这是关于为你的生活创造这样的习惯：这意味着即使你坐在办公桌前，朝九晚五地工作
for the rest of your life. Even if you're stressed, even if you're overwhelmed, there is so much more to life than commitment, so much more to life than responsibility than what other people think, than what you even think. There's a lot of beauty hiding in, I think, the everyday and hiding in our commitment and the love that we show ourselves that really sets us a light that really sparks a fire in our belly to want to live successfully and beautifully and filled with joy. So I just really hope that you enjoyed this episode. I really hope that you've got something out of it. I really hope that you are like on your path to getting your spark back, whether you've lost it because of a breakup, because we've been burnt out, because of whatever it is. You'll find your way back and I hope
余生，你依然会感到充满活力和生气。即使你压力重重，即使你不胜负荷，生活也远不止于承诺，生活远不止于责任、别人的看法、甚至是你自己的看法。我认为，日常生活中隐藏着巨大的美，我们的承诺以及我们对自己展现的爱中隐藏着巨大的美，它们真正点燃了我们，在我们的肚子里点燃了一团火，让我们渴望成功、美丽、充满 joy 地生活。所以我真的希望你喜欢这一期节目。我真的很希望你从中有所收获。我真的很希望你走在找回活力的路上，无论你是因失恋、精疲力竭还是其他什么原因而失去了它。你会找到回归的路，我希望
that this will help you do that. If you enjoyed this episode, please, feel free to leave us a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. I actually really enjoyed this. I'm going to be applying some of these strategies. Obviously, I already do, but I'm really trying to bring more of this into my life. I feel like I've lost way and way a little bit. It happens to the best of us. Make sure that you are following us on Instagram at that psychology podcast or at Gemma Speg if you want to see more behind-the-scenes content, see what's coming out.
这能帮助你做到这一点。如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方给我们留下五星好评。我其实非常喜欢这一期。我也将应用其中一些策略。显然我已经在这么做了，但我真的很想把更多这样的元素带入我的生活。我觉得自己稍微有点迷失方向了。这种情况最优秀的人身上也会发生。确保你在Instagram上关注我们：that psychology podcast或Gemma Speg，如果你想看到更多幕后内容，看看接下来会推出什么。
we actually have something really special coming out in the next month. So if you've made it this far, I guess you're the first to know. I'm not going to tell you exactly what it is, but keep your eyes peeled because, yeah, I'm really excited about it and I hope you are too. We will, of course, be back for another episode next week. Until then, be gentle with yourself, be kind to yourself, and stay safe. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to us.
我们实际上在下个月有一个非常特别的内容推出。所以如果你听到了这里，我想你是第一批知道的人。我不会告诉你具体是什么，但请拭目以待，因为，是的，我对此感到非常兴奋，希望你也是。我们当然会在下周带来另一期节目。在此之前，对自己温柔一点，对自己好一点，注意安全。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听的是
and learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
通过艰难的方式向你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Kear Games学习。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
有多少男人背负着一副盔甲？它向世界发出信号：你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在AHA广播应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《通过艰难的方式学习》（Learn the Hard Way）。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sondland's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
桑德兰女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
这是《陷入爱河的陷阱》（Love Trapped）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《陷入爱河的陷阱》播客。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on. On the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target.
我剖析了在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，心理韧性、健身和建立抗挫力的标志。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你会从另一端走出来，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是数字2%，在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将是他的最后一个目标。
He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他绝不能就这样逃脱惩罚。他将罪有应得。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。收听《闺蜜们》。相信我，宝贝，在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。